hello everyone and welcome to another
moment you've all been waiting for it is
the third day of the aim chest
preliminaries and it is Arjun arigasi
versus Shakir mamadarov playing the
absolute greatest opening there ever was
and will be and that of course is the
Evans Gambit uh I'm not gonna spoil too
much as it's quite the game so let's
dive straight into it Arjun has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have E5 by Shakira Knight to F3 Knights
the C6 and the bishop to C4 now the
Italian game is on the board uh just
give me a second medal wants to come in
the room
sorry about that uh he's a weird dude I
asked him if he wanted to come up he was
like no and now he wants to come in uh
but okay Bishop to see for the Italian
game is on the board Bishop to C5 The
Joker piano and now it finally happens
Pawn to B4 Arjun goes for the Evans
Gambit and there is only one way to play
this and that is to accept the Gambit
Bishop captures on B4 as I always say I
made a nice tutorial on how to play
against this um Bishop to B4 move as
it's the only move that black will play
mostly uh so uh it will be the first
thing in the description below if you
guys are interested in um uh increasing
your vast knowledge on the Evans Gambit
Pawn to C3 and now there are many
possible Retreats here uh even Bishop
fate is mentioned in in that video but
here Bishop to E7 this is the Anderson
variation and it's a very very solid way
of dealing with the evidence Gambit with
Ponte a D4 and now we have D6 and this
is already very interesting as Knight
the A5 is the main way of challenging
this uh this is a an important Square
for the knight in the Evans Gambit
regarding the B3 Square the queen really
wants to come here go after that F7 pawn
and this is perfectly fine for black
even if you go Knight captures an E5 you
as you win that pawn but after Knight
captures Knight captures there's D5
that's a problem and now after e
captures Queen captures you're attacking
the Knight on C4 but also the pawn on G2
so here Knight T3 to attack the queen
and defend opponent now Queen A5 and
it's a very very uh wonderful game but
okay here descends by Mommy Darth and
now we have the captures on E5 now again
as this has all been very thoroughly
analyzed Queen to B3 is the main move
here but black found some very nice
replies how to deal with this yes you
are attacking the F7 Pawn but there's
the very sneaky Knight A5 attacking the
queen and the bishop and the ones to
capture on F7 king of Fate uh Queen to
A4 as your queen is hanging and now King
captures an F7 Queen captures an A5 and
now let's see e captures on D4 you have
all sorts of ideas here like you capture
with the pawn you can even play Queen to
D5 check uh let's say Bishop D6 Queen
captures on B7 and after Queen to C8
sound Queen to B5 moves can be played
with uh some ideas maybe Knight coming
to G5 but it's nothing spectacular like
Knight F6 Knight to G5 King to G8 now
see captors on D4 you will get a strong
Center and white should always be a
little bit better but okay after the 6D
captures on E5 Arjun prepares something
else as that uh Queen the B3 line is
very very analyzed and Tama mirror plays
Knight the H6 this is a new move so
already as of move 7 we have a
completely new game so let's see why
this is uh so powerful of course Arjun
wants to capture that Knight on H6 and
he does he plays Bishop captures on H6
uh but obviously if my major will
offered that well it's uh could be could
be a double-edged sword so G captures an
H6 and now Queen to D2 putting pressure
on that H6 Pawn so Knight captures an E5
Knight captures and now D captures an E5
Queen captures on H6 and now Queen to D6
this was mommy Darrow's idea uh he keeps
the bishop pair he has the open G file
semi-open G file for for his rook and
he's offering a queen trade so if you
don't want to go into uh uh well a
queenless game with something like
captures and captures you have to allow
Mama jar of this very nice setup so
Queen to G7 by Arjun attacking The Rook
Rook to f8 and now Knights the D2 this
Knight here is uh arjun's worst piece uh
for the moment it's really not doing
anything and this is one of the problems
in the events uh if the pawn remains on
C3 or Knight will not be able to come to
C3 so the Knight really wants to come to
C3 to D5 and so on so here at night the
D2 and now comes Queen to F6
and here Mommy Darth could have tried
some other ideas for example if Bishop
the E6 attacking the bishop here how do
you deal with this if Bishop countress
you will play F captures on E6 and now
you're going to Castle Queen side and
it's not gonna be easy for Arjun to play
this especially if you capture the H7
Pawn uh you just give black the
semi-open H file to attack uh White's
King side because you're not staying in
the center you're not going Queen side
so chances are you're going King side
and it's not going to be easy to defend
this so that was one way to do it but
okay my middle went Queen to F6 and
again Arjun declines the queen trade he
goes Queen back to G3 with Bishop to E6
now preparing the castle Queen side
finally get that King away from the
center but Arjun finds a way of keeping
the king in the center just Queen to E3
now guarding that attacking that A7 Pawn
so if you Castle Queen side just Queen
captures on A7 and now Bishop captures
on C4 now you could also play something
like Bishop to D7 but um you you have to
figure out out how to how to properly
Castle as long as the queen is attacking
the spawn that is not happening so okay
my major plays Bishop captures on C4
Knight captures on C4 and now Queen to
E6 attacking the Knight and now Queen to
D3 defending and still preventing
mamajaro from Castle in Queen side and
now the situation on the clock is seven
minutes for Arjun five minutes for
Mahmoud yarov and he goes Rook the d8 so
he says all right I'm not gonna Castle
but I might kick away your queen from
the D file and then a castle
artificially with something like this so
Queen back to E2 still you have to
defend the Knight you can play Queen to
E3 to go after the pawn and now Bishop
to C5
uh this uh will be very useful probably
F5 is happening at some point a DF file
might open up so the F2 Pawn might come
under attack so here we have Knights the
A5 going after the B7 Pawn but mummy
drop nicely defensive with the bishop to
B6 and now well you could capture and B7
uh it's not all that great because Rook
B8 and now the Knight has no retreat
squares so after Bishop to B6 we have
castles uh finally Arjun castles and now
comes Rook to D7 uh interestingly if you
capture the Knight here it's not uh
gonna work because Queen B5 check
regains material and now white is just
the white is just perfectly fine so
after this Castle we've rooked the D7 by
mamidarov and now Knight the C4 yeah the
Knight is now coming to E3 and then to
D5 or F5 depending on what black plays
so Pawn to F6 also adding defense to the
E5 pawn pawn to a for preparing A5 and
now Bishop the C5 we have Knight the E3
and now King to d8 mamajaro is now
finally confident to cross that bridge
and bring the king over to the queen
side situation on the clock two and a
half minutes for Arjuna in two minutes
for uh Rook after D1 and now King the C8
so mamidara was successfully uh
artificially castles Queen side Rook
capture Sunday seven Queen captures and
now uh you wanna get your Rook into the
game but for the moment the A4 Pawn will
be hanging and also you have to create
some breathing room for your king as uh
for the moment your king is very weak on
that back rank so Rook to d8 now and now
Rook to D1 attacking the queen queen to
E6 and this is the moment where it all
happens here Arjun has to decide of
course you should not trade you are you
are attacking or at least you are trying
to prove you're the one who's attacking
and you have to play Knight to D5 the
Knight on D5 is an excellent piece you
don't want to trade and then you're
gonna try to play something like Queen
to B5 maybe bring The Rock entire game
may be pushed upon there are some
attacking ideas here and of course if
you try something like C6 it's not all
that impressive just Queen to C4 even
ideas like these are are possible here
and now you see captures on D5 there's
Queen captures and C5 with the check
after King B8 there's a rook captures on
D5 and all of a sudden it's white who is
winning you're up a pawn your position
is better nowhere in the world so after
Queen T6 this is what you sorry this is
what you should play but Arjun played
Knights the F5 and this is just um this
is just a straight out blunder and I'm
sure you guys realize why it's a blunder
but just in case you don't uh feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only winning idea for mama yarov uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the pawn on A4 is hanging and that the
F2 Pawn is very weak those two combined
allow us to find the next maneuver and
that is Rook captures on D1 so
congratulations to everyone who founded
this uh you are a a a great spotter of
only winning lines Queen captures on D1
and now Queen to A2 attacking A4 and
also threatening Queen captures on F2 so
uh this is the the greater evil you have
to defend against this queen to F3 by
Arjun and now not even immediately
capturing First Pawn to A5 preparing
Pawn to B5 uh Knight to H6 Arjun has to
figure out how to reach that black king
that's the only way you're gonna not
lose this game Pawn to B5 now Knight the
G4 we have B captures an A4 now Queen
captures an F6 and now Pawn to A3 Mama
they are just going all out here on the
queen side now disregarding everything
Arjun is doing a king the G2 and now
King the B7 a safety move uh so you
don't have to worry about all the checks
uh Queen captures on E5 now attacking
the bishop but just Queen to C4 getting
the queen out of the way of the pawn and
also defending the bishop and C5 Knight
to F6 Pawn to A2 and now Knights the E8
attacking that C7 Pawn but the shot here
just goes a bishop to B6 with Queen to
E7 uh now trying to destroy some trouble
but just Queen to C5 and he was in this
position on move 38 that Arjun erigasi
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here your queen is
attacked of course if you trade Queens
nothing good can come of it as the next
move uh Mama jar will just Queen the
pawn and if you don't uh also your F2
Pawn is hanging so you don't have time
for some uh for for some ideas here even
though it's very hard to find any ideas
uh as long as the queen was here there
was always the thread of just light the
D6 check as the C Pawn is pinned so this
would pick up the queen but now after
Queen to C5 there are no such tricks and
well here here we just resign there's no
no way to defend against Queen captures
on F2 and also A1 Queen so very nicely
done by by both of them uh big
congratulations to Mommy Darwin taking
down Arjun playing the greatest opening
of all and also big congratulations to
Arjun and taking as uh well such a such
a fine decision on on trying to win a
game with the Evans Gambit and as you've
seen uh even a player like Mama jarro
who's been creating brilliantly after
brilliancy did not have an easy time
taming this um this Beast or of an
opening uh had Arjun found this Knight
to F5 in The crucial moment instead of
knights the D5 and Knight the D5 instead
of Knight to F5 uh it's still a
completely crazy game uh but yeah played
well as he has been playing the entire
tournament and he was able to win this
one after Queen C5 Arjun resigned and
that's it a brilliant game by mama jarov
uh so there you have it that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it if you were if
you're interested in learning more about
the Evans Gambit do click on the link in
the description below uh it's my own
tutorial on how to play this opening a
lot of people are interested it has
almost a million views so I imagine a
lot of people are playing the Evans
Gambit uh I would like to thank Duncan
wine called a woman life Freedom Lord of
Chess Anderson Vira and Antonio
Hernandez Espin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day